this was supposed to be the first week
of summer vacation for the students of
robb elementary school instead on
tuesday ten-year-old amari joe garza was
laid to rest in the first of 21 funerals
for the victims of last week's mass
shooting in uvalde texas it's beautiful
and they're really it's really pretty
but of course you can't see her it's
close casket so you know
but there's pictures of her everywhere
services for ten-year-old maita juliano
rodriguez are also being held at a
funeral home across the street from the
school where she was killed for the
upcoming funeral of ellie garcia her
family plans to mourn her in an open
casket despite her wounds
president joe biden who visited uvalde
on sunday lamented to new zealand's
prime minister jacinda ardern the
frequency with which he tours the scene
of human devastation there's an awful
lot of suffering we've been
i've been
to more
mass shooting after mass than i think
any present american history
unfortunately
and it's uh it's just
so much of it is
much of it is preventable and the
devastation is
is amazing
new zealand tightened its national gun
laws within a week of a 2019 mass
shooting there that left more than 50
dead in the united states political
gridlock has prevented any similar
action
the shootings in uvalde were so horrific
that mayor don mclaughlin says the site
should be raised to the ground i don't
think anybody's plans are but to tear
that building down and it needs to be
torn down
i would never ask expect a child to have
to ever walk in those doors ever
and ever again
with funeral homes overwhelmed by the
number of victims in this town of 16 000
services for all 21 are expected to take
weeks to complete john hendren al
jazeera